[Applaudissements]
ces deux copains qui se rencontrent il y
en a un qui dit à l'autre tu vas bien
lotis fait extrêmement bien et 10 dans
deux mois je suis milliardaire je fais
mais bon pourquoi pas 10 parce que j'ai
inventé un procédé révolutionnaire et là
le monde entier est en train de se
l'arracher
c'est à la fois écolo c'est fait c'est
vraiment une entreprise 2.0 moussavi
avant midi c'est quoi il dit j'ai trouvé
le moyen de transformer la merde
amber sait ce qu'est ce que c'est que
ces conneries là lucie net à 2 km je
t'emmène vous titille ben ouais je veux
bien faire ça arrive un truc sur 5
hectares on a poli un truc sublime je
rentre plus l'intrigué bombe à la la la
la première machine bon bah c'est le lay
se passe dans un premier trio première
transformation l'a clairement à deux
kilomètres là bas tu vois c'est la
deuxième transformation
ici elle conditionnement elle arrive
devant eux une motte de beurre
c'est incroyable a dit ces bombes à dire
goutte comme suivre à bout de pales qui
donne à son pote le christ a quand même
un goût de merde hein ah ben oui
[Rires]
[Musique]
alors celle de tina ses deux pieds pis
on veut pas vu depuis un certain temps
et il se croiser il fait bon tu vois il
fait faire voir que si on fait ce week
end
moi j'étais qovu tient à deauville
ouais dis moi tu es tu au casino -
comment ça s'est passé
bon aure voit que de raconter alors m
après coup argent rfi liffran j'avais
oublié qu'ils font et ça occasion car
oui répond aux hasards a osé dire à ces
gens mais le soin 8 avant ce m'a dit
qu'est ce que c'est beau c'est eric il
se lie à ça m'a dit tu as gagné 36 x 10
x
ouais je savais et brille tout aimé ce
oui tu fout quoi de voir où et qui s'est
passé oui que je voyais un plus petit
que ça fait partie de mon temps perdu
non voilà faire durer trois heures
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
dans une heure il raconté ça fait un
mois qu'on l'aimé
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
quant à toute remise sur le mythe n'ont
rien qui puisse arriver avec un crayon
un peuple est il m'a fait monter avec
bobby schumi cadre qu'est ce qui s'est
passé c'est [ __ ] de merde moi le type
là le spécial le maintien j'aurais mangé
les couilles de coiffure
[Applaudissements]
samedi garçons sa mère à lui dit va nous
acheter de la confiture pénurie qu'on
voit le quartier il y va y rentre chez
l'épicier dit écoute maman t'a dit de
lui la conviction dit ça tombe bien j'ai
une confiture qui vient d'arriver des
états unis le petit prend la confiture
et fait rentrer chez lui mais sur le
chemin idéal s'est passé dit il faut que
je bouge alors les louves le truc il a
goûté j'y arrive pas par là il arrive
c'est sa mère du mahb où je vais mais
c'est pas possible d'un mois le pot ale
trop le policier on a fait deux fois que
je le perds il sort mieux c'est quoi ce
bordel
lucky la confiture le pôle n'est pas
possible cette famille c'est pas
possible il par énerver chez l'épicier
vous m'avez j'en ai à [ __ ] c'est pas
content vos concerts au québec
sur le chemin il connait pas le chemin
par novartis alors ils croisent mais
excusez moi le commissariat claude geay
de manger un pour l autre gilles
faiblesse
[Rires]
[Musique]
c'est un routier
je le mets là pardon faire un peu
d'ombré mais j'adore c'est un routier
conseil sur le saut torture ou le coup
il voit un petit nain rouges eux en
plein milieu de la route et là mais
c'est vite dit qu'ici vous arrive à
chine a aussi dit chez ma voiture qui a
glissé dans le fossé
je sais plus quoi faire jour mariage de
mon frère je peux pas être à jeun treuil
à l'arrière il n'y a pas de souci
garrigues le camion l'accroché de
voitures duc chinh à un rouge grand père
du ressort du fossé et août sinon lui
dit vous êtes formidables rechange
je sais pas quoi faire pour vous
remercier vous avez été tellement
chantier routier dit ça est sur la route
on s'entraide
c'est tout non mais dis je peux pas vous
laisser partir comme ça si vous voulez
par exemple j'aurais pu vous sucer la
[ __ ]
je savais que ça les ventes de pc ont
subi
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voyez-vous le routier le routier dit non
mais dis ça pas dit d'où sortait 10e ils
laissent pas le temps aux routiers de
réfléchir le routier contre le camion
lui déboutonne très vite la braguette
charmant dans sa part le widget et qui
croient qu'il ya bien un rouge remontent
dans son camion 20 kilomètres plus loin
un petit nom
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dix ans la vie tu dis qu'est ce qui vous
arrive
abba et 10g ma voiture qui démarre plus
chez à l'enterrement de ma long mais on
ne veut pas louper la cérémonie c'est
dans une heure je dis rien d'arena
seychelles coup d'oeil il ouvre le capot
pas dit oui c'est la courroie qui est
ptc pour ça l'alternateur recharge s'est
dit j'ai toujours un bout de ficelle
il m'avoue vie c'est le taquine la tâche
dix essais pour voir de vignes et guérin
tarauder marc referme le cas pour le
sien jaune a dit je sais pas comment
vous remercier
c'est l'étiquette mot gentil anti-héros
ça ça va je viens de voir un pote à vous
la formidable c'est bon pour moi c'est
celle est nickel à dinan mais je me
permets d'insister
je dirais présente si vous aviez voulu
m'occuper
c'est un panneau hélas le petit nain
jaune et lui laisse pas le temps de
réfléchir aux routiers le plat contre le
camion il se retourne très vite mais
souvent revu
et regarde puis réduits à dix avant la
caméra cachée c'est quoi ce bordel c'est
comme ça faisait au début j'étais seul
au monde dans cinq avions 20 km et quoi
se passe partout
un petit nain bleu vote plein milieu de
la route
ouais ouais mais ça les animaux qu'est
ce que tu veux toi tu aimes 6edu
lecoeuche aucune gendarmerie
[Applaudissements]
alors si une femme c'est son
anniversaire elle veut absolument un
perroquet elle fait tout les percutent y
ait du monde de paris de la banlieue de
tout être pas de perroquets elle est
très très triste elle veut s'acheter un
perroquet c'est très important pour elle
tout est finalement rentré chez elle
passe devant un bibi horrible un vieux
perruquier qui vend des perroquets elle
dit monsieur vous resterez question à
l'inversé très important pour moi il
fait j'ai pas de perroquets il fait mais
le perroquet que je vois derrière vous
là au fond là qui a une drôle de tête
van madame pas celui-là pas celui-là je
peux pas vous vend super ok c'est
impossible
elle dit mais pourrait ici parce que
madame se paie vous qu'il est très
spécial il va vous gênez il va vous
poser des problème croyez moi il va vous
poser problème elle échoue m'en fous je
mens vous - les verts je suis ok il dit
écoutez je vous préviens super ok il a
été élevé dans un bordel alors il a un
langage assez ouvert je m'en fous je
m'en fous je vois un perroquet elle
rentre chez elle même pocus sur ce qu'on
perçoit elle se change pour elle à faire
la fête avec des copies et à peine elle
sort elle et dont près de la porte mon
père qui fait et ce alors tu vas faire
la fête
tu vas te faire trancher elle est un peu
vexée elle s'en fout elle est contente
elle à son père qu'elle s'en va il
revient à 4 heures du matin il est là il
fait de savoir comment ça s'est passé
tu t'es fait déglinguer convient mais
sans fouille se couche le lendemain pour
un petit déjeuner
[Rires]
je vous la fais et donc je vous la fait
se voir accuser campagne aller très loin
non non non non non je peux passer trop
à la maison oui alors elle va elle
rentre le soir tu marches une drôle de
manière
ça tu faire mal un peu plus alors le
percuter mais bonjour monsieur ne
percute et il a quand même été une
solution une recette pour qu'ils se
calment effet cyril dessel côté j'ai une
idée je sais pas si ça va marcher je
suis pas là cette bombe de peinture
c'est une bombe
ap hockey alors c'est la peinture noire
d'equidia mon mal élevés vous rentrez
chez vous le payez en noir elle rentre à
la maison il arrive
[Musique]
[Rires]
enfin ça s'est passé
elle prend la bombe de peinture il est
noir et à ce moment-là il dit plus rien
elle sort le soir elle revient quatre
heures du matin il dit rien le matin il
dit rien l'après midi il dit rien au
bout de toujours elle regarda faire leur
espèce de petit con à te connais tu la
fermes ta gueule 1 et l'affectif et
quand je suis on se moque je prends pas
oublié
[Applaudissements]